في سن الثلاثين ، شعر ديف كونواي
بانخفاض مستوى طاقته ، لقد كان متعبًا في كثير من الأحيان
ولم يتمكن من الارتداد كما كان معتادًا ،
وعندما أتحدث إلى الناس حول هذا الأمر ،
سيكونون مرحبًا بهم في
التقدم في السن يومًا ما في العمل.  بذل
نفسه وشعر بغثيان خفيف ،
اعتقد أنه كان إجهادًا حراريًا في
البداية ولكن الأعراض استمرت وبمرور
الوقت أصيب بحرقة في المعدة
وضيق في التنفس عندما لم
يتحسن تم تشجيعه على الذهاب
إلى الطبيب بعد رؤية
ضغط دمه  تم إرسال كونواي على الفور إلى
غرفة الطوارئ حيث كان لديه
مخطط صدى القلب أي شيء أقل من 40
يعتبر فشلًا في القلب وكنت في العاشرة
ويقول كونواي إنه أصيب بثلاث سكتات دماغية في
المستشفى ، ثم
تم اكتشاف انسداد 100 في الشريان الرئيسي.
كانت الأعراض السابقة في الواقع علامات
على نوبة قلبية Widowmaker
قال طبيب القلب الذي أتعامل معه إن لم أحضر عندما
فعلت ذلك ، ربما كنت قد ذهبت إلى
الفراش في تلك الليلة ولم يستيقظ
طبيب القلب لاكشمي أبدًا مع
مركز ويكسنر الطبي بجامعة ولاية أوهايو.
الجميع
بغض النظر عن العمر لمعرفة الأعراض
بما في ذلك عدم الراحة في الصدر أو الألم الذي
ينتشر إلى الكتف الخلفي والرقبة أو
ضيق الفك في التنفس غثيان عسر
الهضم إرهاق شديد ، هناك
شيء جديد تمامًا
ولا معنى لذلك ، فأنت تريد البحث عن
طبي فوري  بعد خمس سنوات ،
ركز كونواي على أسلوب
حياة صحي ، أدركت أنني سعيد
لوجودي هنا اليوم من أجل الصحة الدقيقة ، أنا آندي
جاثر
[موسيقى]